alguna zona de jarquín no son una opción
para vivir en estos momentos
muchos edificios permanecen abandonados
y bombardeados desde hace meses y sus
habitantes no han vuelto
El capitán de policía vital Isidro nos
permite acompañarles en un patrullaje
por las calles de la ciudad la tarea de
estos agentes consiste en proteger las
propiedades y hacer frente a la
criminalidad en tiempos de guerra
vayamos al distrito de harking conocido
como el barrio de saltive canote donde
ocurrieron las peores batallas al
principio es la zona que más sufrió
ahora
este barrio donde antes vivía medio
millón de personas ahora está casi
desierto la policía dice que la
situación está bajo control pero si han
aumentado las personas en estado de
ebriedad y los robos
[Música]
la dificultad de trabajar en estas zonas
es que muchas personas se han ido de
este lugar y han dejado aquí sus cosas y
algunos merodeadores rompen las ventanas
suben y roban cosas que eran de la gente
es la más grande ciudad del este de
Ucrania afectada por la guerra nunca ha
estado bajo ocupación rusa pero la
situación está lejos de la normalidad
muchas tiendas están cerradas los niños
solo tienen clase a distancia y es
prácticamente imposible encontrar una
calle sin destrozos
las sirenas en jarquín suenan varias
veces al día en algunas ocasiones los
misiles también caen en edificios
civiles la instrucción se acumula en
medio de edificaciones sin ventanas y
agujereados por los disparos
pero la ciudad también se esfuerza por
resistir en esta esquina olega y su
compañero intentan alegrar a las
personas con sus canciones para ganarse
algunas monedas
ahora con la guerra trabajamos afuera
somos músicos profesionales nuestra
profesión es animar a la gente también
para que puedan soportar lo que está
ocurriendo ahora
dice que no dejará de tocar en la calle
como tanto jarkovitas no se resigna a
que su ciudad sea solo sinónimo de
tristeza
[Música]